hey welcome to your new project camp
update so we bought this big piece of
land and are prototyping a more
sustainable way of living
not sure how it's going to go but let's
see and in the previous video you could
see
us while doing a lot of things really
and which means we have documented and
made a lot of videos
and videos is kind of essential for this
project because
99.9 of the people would never see this
place in real life
but they see it through a digital screen
so having good documentation and good
video
is crucial and i would say
it's been decreasing a little bit i've
gotten a bit more annoyed making videos
due to the camera i was using so i'm
going to show you
a new camera which i got we also have
two boxes to open up from people that
send some old camera gear
so we can have more angles as we work
but before we dive into the world of
cameras
uh we first need to help the neighbors
because they asked us to help out
harvesting some potatoes and they have
land
right here
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
how is it dave yeah it's good hard work
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
buckets full of potatoes
[Music]
david
we just harvest all of the potatoes
which is
nearly not this way more
so antonio will take now to a place
where they stir them for the year
and we will have a little bushel which
is a little snack
nice how many kilograms potatoes did we
harvest
today we harvested about 600 kilos
in total this year they harvested about
1700 kilos
a lot of potatoes
[Music]
you
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
a new gift big gift
we have a lot of onion soup
all right so let's talk about cameras
here i have a new sony
zv1 yeah it's one of those small compact
cameras
apparently good for video taking and
vlogging on the go which i do a lot
someone donated from the community thank
you for that so we can upgrade our video
quality
i've actually been using it for the last
few videos some of you noticed that the
image quality got way better
no no one actually but i know and the
main reason to get it is actually not
per se the image quality but there are a
few
very annoying things about the camera
i'm currently using but let me change
them
alright so now you see the new camera
and here's the old one
it's a canon g7x mark iii
i used to have the mark ii which i liked
a lot and then i changed
to mark iii i never really liked it
there are a few things which are just
very annoying to me the main one
is that it should film in 4k but
actually it overheats after two minutes
the only moment that i didn't have any
problems was in siberia when it was -17
so we're currently halfway in the middle
of siberia
in time to get some fresh air
and it seems doable because it's cold
like really cold so the camera
was not overheating has a lot of
problems with autofocus so that's why a
lot of shots are often out of focus
this is also a known issue they even say
that out of focus on a previous model
was better
this is a bit of a detail but the main
reason i got this camera or upgraded
back then
was because you could add external audio
so you have an inlet to put your audio
jack
but it actually does have a mount where
you could slide in your microphone
so you have to buy this external thing
so you can slide in your microphone
kinda silly makes the camera much more
bulky
and recently the screen broke as you can
see here
not a big deal but sometimes the touch
doesn't work which doesn't help focusing
i started to notice that i got really
annoyed using that camera because it's
either not in focus or it overheats
especially when summer is coming so now
we have a new camera hopefully quality
goes up but also less frustration
during the filming process so you might
wonder if quality is important why not
use a dslr camera
i have one but to be honest i rarely use
it because
a lot of complex settings to get into it
takes more time to set up with a tripod
it doesn't really fit into every corner
so realistically i rarely use this one
only if i really shoot
a long setting which runs as an
interview with the neighbors but the
day-to-day activities or all the
progress we make
98 of that is filmed with this small
camera
anyway just wanted to give you guys a
heads up on that and thank you very much
for donating this camera
now it's time to open up these two boxes
both boxes are coming from germany
and one actually took a long time to
arrive due to some post
problems
alright so first we have a sony action
cam which you can use for time lapses
and when we go into the water
also it comes with a lot of accessories
handheld tripod with the camera on
and the back with
stabilizer where you can mount the
camera on top i never really used one of
these things actually but seems very
useful when walking around to to bushy
bumpy roots cool thanks
feels like christmas next up
it's a lot of paper
[Music]
so here we have an osmo pocket
also stabilizer to walk around gopro 7
still in packaging it is all second hand
but i guess they took proper care of it
we have this thing is big
just a box full of gopro accessories
wow and there's even a selfie stick
inside
i was never the owner of selfie stick
but uh
2021 is coming baby
and the reason for people to send this
stuff is not random
a few updates ago i asked for some gear
if you want to record yearly time lapses
so gopros are good for that and we also
had a section on support.projectcom.com
where we mentioned we want to upgrade
our camera gear so a special thanks to
sandra
atam uh d jennifer and phillip for
sending out their things
now we're actually still looking for
people that also want to do more
photography and video making here on the
land to capture wildlife
the other day we actually saw a few
foxes here
super cool one actually came very close
into the container right here
and finally we could still use help
making yearly time lapses you can also
find that on the website
the main reason for that is that there's
going to be a lot of progress and a lot
of development here on project camp but
it's long term it's going to take a
while
and we use time lapses a lot but usually
they last like what an hour two hours
very short and here we would really need
a yearly time lapse which means a
picture every day
so for that you need to have a bit of a
different configuration and setup
we now have a few cameras we can play
with but i'm not sure how to do it
so if you have suggestions uh you can go
to the discord
or uh sign up on support.projectcom.com
if you want to
come here set it up and really start
making these timelapses anyway thank you
guys all for watching it's really cool
to have this community helping out
around the whole project still small
it's growing
but already super cool to receive some
of your old cameras
which are still very useful for us so
yeah thanks a lot
and see you in the next video